dritte aufreger heute früh für dich ja
die robert koch institut zahlen die im
kahlen die irgendwie ja nie richtig
stimmten in dieser ganzen carola krise
man hat doch nicht so viel zeit gehabt
um die zusammen nur zwei jahre ja nur
und jetzt stimmen diese zahlen irgendwie
immer noch nicht so richtig oder doch
oder nicht also das lka hatte ja in der
ganzen corona panini einen
heiligenschein muss man schon sagen jede
kritik jedes anzweifeln auch von zahlen
das kam gotteslästerung gleich aber wir
stellen jetzt fest das rkw spieler muss
von seinem hohen ross heruntersteigen
dieses institut ist entthront
denn es hat jetzt selbst umfragen vom rk
ii gegeben wonach ja die zahlen
derjenigen die in deutschland gehen
wurden viel zu niedrig angegeben sind in
wirklichkeit gibt es rund drei millionen
3,5 millionen mehr personen die schon
geimpft wurden als das rk ii offiziell
ausweis und das bedeutet dass maßnahmen
auch in den ländern die getroffen und
immer auf basis falscher zahlen
getroffen waren zumindest was die
impfquote angeht aber sich der einzige
fall wir erinnern uns an weihnachten
2020 an ostern 20 21 auch danach gab es
ja immer lockt downs und auch da hatte
das lka über wochen schwierigkeiten
konkrete zahlen was die zahl der
infizierten angeht herauszufinden also
auch da wurde mit zahl agiert die er so
im ungefähren waren das heißt wir haben
viele der korona maßnahmen auf basis
unsicherer zahlen dann am ende
entschieden und durchgesetzt das ist
natürlich verheerend vor allem die
impfquote ganz entscheidende zahl auch
bei der durchsetzung von maßnahmen auch
immer wieder eine zeit die angewendet
wurde im internationalen vergleich und
immer wieder wurde gesagt da liegen wir
so weit hinten immer wieder wurde in
aussicht gestellt wenn wir diese oder
jene zahl auch da wurde ja schon wird
jan mit den zahlen da er 80 prozent und
dann haben wir endlich dann kommen die
freiheiten wieder zurück jetzt heute an
diesem tag wir schauen in den herbst in
den winter hinein stehen wir irgendwie
man kann schon gar nicht hören am selben
punkt richtig und wir sind ungefähr wenn
man das jetzt hochrechnet die zahlen die
jetzt ja auch vom rk ii mehr oder
weniger bestätigt wurden wenn man das
hochrechnet liegen wir ungefähr dort auf
dem gleichen impfquoten niveau bei dem
auch dänemark liegt wir wissen dass
dänemark der seit mehr als vier wochen
die totale freiheit hat also das heißt
eigentlich dänemark ist zurück in einem
ganz normalen leben modus hat alle
corona beschränkungen aufgehoben hat
corona jetzt als einfach nur noch
gefährliche einfach nur noch in
anführungsstrichen aber gefährliche
krankheit eingestuft da müssten wir mit
den zahlen die wir jetzt haben auch in
und es gibt noch einen weiteren punkt
wer entschuldigt sich eigentlich bei den
ganzen kindern beispielsweise die er nun
extrem über monate in dieser pandemie
gelitten haben weil die schulen nicht
dort gefallen haben wir sehen einen
dramatischen zuwachs an adipositas
patienten patienten mit essstörungen
gerade im bereich auch der jugendlichen
wer aufgrund dieser falschen zahl
entschuldigt sich jetzt eigentlich bei
den kindern sagt hoops tut uns leid da
lagen wir wohl ein bisschen daneben das
war wohl zu vorstellen das hat es bisher
nicht gegeben und das erwarte ich
eigentlich auch von lothar wieler dass
er sich da entschuldigung sagt unsere
zahlen war nicht immer sauber leider hat
es deswegen fehleinschätzungen und das
nachdem das lka immer ganz fix diese im
quoten festgelegt hat die erreicht
werden müssen als 75% dann 80 prozent
und jetzt weiß man gar nicht ob diese im
quote eben erfüllt ist oder nicht man
geht grob zwischen 50 und 90 impfquote
offenbar hakt feldhaus dem robert koch
institut
ja das ist richtig also es ist hoch
geschraubt wurden immer wieder 60
prozent waren es im sommer und dann kam
die sogenannte data variante und an
dieses plötzlich jetzt brauchen wir
eigentlich eher 80 prozent man wird
sicherlich auch noch was neues erfinden
lothar wieler hat ja kürzlich auch sogar
davon gesprochen dass die grippe
eigentlich in vielen dingen dem koma
virus sehr ähnliches gerade was die
ansteckungswege angeht also da die frage
wenn man das jetzt schon auf eine stufe
auch wieder hebt was auch verpönt war
über monate da wurde man als querdenker
fresh verschriebene man das gemacht hat
aber das macht der lkw chef jetzt selbst
erhebt das auf die gleiche stufe ja was
bedeutet das eigentlich jetzt für den
herbst bleibt die maske für immer wird
es wieder ein lockdown diesmal hat eine
grippe lockdown geben also man hat schon
den eindruck dass rk ii ist immer wieder
dabei uns in diesem pandemie modus sehr
sehr gerne zu halten
[Musik]